in this video we'll talk about T Cell
Activation
T Cell Activation take place when T Cell
interacts with the antigen presenting
cells such as the dendritic cell before
understanding the cellular and molecular
events in T Cell Activation let us begin
from the basics
T Cell develops in the bone marrow and
it all starts from the hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell
from there it develops into lymphoid
progenitor from the lymphoid progenitor
T Cell precursors are generated and they
leave the bone marrow to reach the
thymus and in the thymus there is
stringent training that these T Cell
precursors get once these T-cell
precursors leave the thymus they have T
cell receptors and a co-receptor in this
case CD4
but these cells are actually
naive T cells that means they have not
encountered any antigens so far and they
are right now in a quiescent state that
means in g0 phase
these T cells are circulating that means
they get circulated into the bloodstream
and move here and there
anyway at this point of time T cells has
condensed chromatin not much
transcriptional activity is going on in
these T cells and they have very little
proportion of cytoplasm as well
now these cells move from one place to
another throughout the body
and they possibly encountered the
dendritic cell in this process
it it is found that these T cells are
circulating among the blood lymph node
and the secondary lymphoid tissue in
every 24 hours
in this time course they can possibly
encounter a dendritic cell let's see
what happens in this encounter dendritic
cells are antigen presenting cells that
means they can present an antigen on top
of Class 2 MHC molecule this class 2 MHC
molecule can be recognized by T Cell
receptor this T Cell receptor mediated
signaling is really important for T Cell
Activation indeed this is the first
signal that is required for a T Cell
Activation
there are other receptors present in the
T cells such as cd28 which is a
cost-stimulatory receptor it interacts
with the CD 80 or cd86 receptors on the
tendritic cell
and this interaction gives the signal 2
for activation
other than these two interactions the
cytokine signaling is the third signal
which leads to a T Cell Activation and
the key cytokine for T Cell Activation
is interleukin-2
once there are three signals like this
the T cell would now re-enter the cell
cycle
they would proliferate rapidly this is
known as clonal expansion
after proliferating rapidly
they could be differentiated into
several sub lineages based on the
cytokines they encounter they could
become th1 cell th17 cell T follicular
cell or even th2 cells even some of them
become T memory cell in future if you
want to learn in this process in details
that means the T cell differentiation
process in details the link is found in
the I button or in the description
now let me tell you that in T cells cd28
are not the only co-stumulatory receptor
along with cd28 icos is another
co-stimulatory receptor
now icos can interact with the icos
ligand present in the activated
dendritic cells
and these kind of interaction is super
important for the effector T cells now
the naive T cell does not express the
icos molecule but effector T cell does
it is also found in the memory T cells
it is thought that these icos receptors
are required for maintaining activated
state
now the
positive stimulation is not the only
type of interaction that happens in case
of a T cell
there are negative core stimulatory
receptor as well such as ctla now the
ctla and cd80 interaction leads to an
inactivation of
T Cell responses
that means these uh positive and
negative co-stimulatory receptors
maintain a balance of T cell activity
indeed there are several negative core
stimulatory receptor present in the T
cell and these negative co-stimulation
ensures
that T cell hyperactivation can be
prevented
now in summary we learned that T Cell
Activation requires the interaction
between antigen presenting cells like
dendritic cells and T cells there are
three distinct signals which are
required for the activation of T cells
and we learned about all of them
and we learned the importance of
cytokine
interleukin-2 we also looked at T cell
has positive and negative co-stimulatory
receptor
and we learned that once activated they
can be differentiated into different
subclasses
so if you want more videos and notes
lectures all of these can be found in my
Facebook page or in my Instagram page my
handle is provided here it the links are
provided in the description
you can support our channel in patreon
or in beam UPI also under each video
there is an option for super thanks
which is present in the bottom right
corner of the video you can contribute
using paytm PayPal or UPI
if you wish to connect to me all my
social media links are provided in the
description you can also support the
nerd medic Channel all the link for
these nutmeg channel is given in the
description as well feel free to connect
don't forget to comment see you in the
next video